Android Studio is
evolving rapidly.
If you'd like to get a
preview of the next release
but don't want to risk
your productivity,
you can keep two copies of
Android Studio installed
side-by-side.
If you haven't already, start by
downloading the stable release
from the Android Developer site.
Then, head over to
tools.android.com and grab
a copy of the
latest Canary build.
Install each into
different locations.
Now of course,
the whole point is
to keep a stable build
on one and the cutting
edge on the other.
So open up the Preferences
on your stable installation,
navigate to System
Settings and Updates,
and make sure the
Automatically Check Updates
checkbox is checked.
Then select Stable.
Now do the same for your preview
installation, only this time
select the Canary channel
from the Update settings.
You've also got the option of
setting either channel to Beta,
which is the channel used
for release candidates
before they're pushed
out through Stable.
You can change the channel
used for updating your stable
or preview installation
at any time.
Either case, if you encounter
a bug, use the Help,
Submit Feedback menu
to file a bug directly
with the Android Studio team.
You'll be notified of new
versions of Android Studio
for the relevant
channel on restart,
or you can force a
check by selecting Check
For Updates at any time.